la diabetes tipo 1 es una condición en
la cual su páncreas no produce insulina
una hormona que el cuerpo necesita para
mantener los niveles apropiados de
azúcar en la sangre
después que usted come alimentos que
contienen hidratos de carbono
los productos químicos en el intestino
delgado los descomponen en moléculas de
azúcar simple llamadas glucosa
luego las células que recubren el
intestino delgado absorben la glucosa
la cual pasa al torrente sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas las
células beta del páncreas detectan el
incremento de los niveles de glucosa
las células beta liberan insulina en el
torrente sanguíneo para reducir los
niveles de glucosa y para mantener la
glucosa sanguínea en un nivel saludable
la mayoría de las células del cuerpo
tienen ciertos receptores en su
superficie que se unen a la insulina
circulante
la insulina actúa como la llave de una
cerradura para abrir la célula de tal
manera que la glucosa circulante puede
ingresar a dicha célula
ahora sus células pueden utilizar la
glucosa para producir la energía que
necesitan para funcionar correctamente
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1 las
células beta del páncreas pierden su
capacidad de producir insulina dando
como resultado altos niveles de glucosa
en la sangre y otras complicaciones
en la diabetes tipo 1 su sistema
inmunológico específicamente sus
glóbulos blancos consideran a las
células beta pancreáticas como si fueran
cuerpos extraños
en una respuesta autoinmune sus glóbulos
blancos segregan anticuerpos que
destruyen a sus propias células beta
como resultado el páncreas produce poca
o ninguna insulina
sin la insulina la glucosa no puede
ingresar a sus células dichas células
están desnutridas debido a la falta de
las calorías que deberían recibir de la
glucosa
además el nivel de glucosa se acumula en
el torrente sanguíneo dando lugar a una
condición llamada hiperglucemia
los síntomas más comunes de la
hiperglucemia en la diabetes tipo 1 son
excesiva hambre y sed
necesidad de orinar frecuentemente
pérdida de peso inexplicable
fatiga debilidad irritabilidad y visión
borrosa
si la hiperglucemia no se trata usted
puede enfermarse gravemente debido a que
usted no tiene suficiente insulina en la
sangre las células no pueden utilizar la
glucosa para obtener energía
como resultado su cuerpo descompone las
reservas de grasa y de proteínas como
fuente alternativa de energía a medida
que la descomposición de la grasa
continúa ciertos subproductos conocidos
como cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan en la
sangre dando lugar a una condición
llamada cetosis cuando los cuerpos
cetónicos se acumulan a niveles
peligrosamente altos se produce una
condición llamada cetoacidosis diabética
que puede poner en peligro la vida si
sus niveles de glucosa en sangre siguen
siendo altos en el tiempo se pueden
producir problemas de salud a largo
plazo tales como la aterosclerosis
ceguera
daño a los nervios
y enfermedad renal
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1 su
meta es mantener su glucosa en sangre
dentro de los niveles normales esto se
realiza a través de una combinación
adecuada de reemplazo de la insulina
monitoreo de la glucosa en sangre y de
igual importancia seguir una dieta
saludable y hacer ejercicios de forma
regular
debido a que su páncreas deja de
producir insulina usted deberá
administrarse insulina para reemplazar
la que su cuerpo debería producir un
profesional médico autorizado puede
entrenarlo para que usted se inyecte la
insulina de manera subcutánea usted
deberá administrarse varias inyecciones
al día
frotando el punto de aplicación para
evitar daños en los tejidos y problemas
de absorción
otra forma de administrarse la insulina
es a través de una bomba de insulina la
cual está adherida a su cuerpo y le
administra la insulina a través de un
tubo que está implantado bajo su piel
usted tendrá que revisar el nivel de
glucosa en la sangre varias veces al día
con un glucómetro
para ello debe pinchar su dedo con una
aguja pequeña llamada lanceta
y colocar una gota de sangre en el
glucómetro
conocer su nivel de glucosa en la sangre
le permite ajustar su dosis de insulina
las calorías que usted come durante las
comidas y la actividad física que
realice
usted deberá seguir una dieta saludable
y realizar ejercicios de forma regular
para controlar su nivel de glucosa y
reducir el riesgo de sufrir enfermedades
cardiovasculares